there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody its episode 140
yeah we got a good one this is another
true crime one
yeah serial killer stuff yeah this has
been recommended multiple times yeah
this is the Canadian serial killer
Robert Willy picton yeah everything is
the pig farmer killer the episode we
just did the black hopes episode I guess
like who don't know that's about that
was the ghost case that poltergeist
poltergeist is based upon yeah so you
know it's not getting a whole lot of
hits but just letting you guys know you
can go back there and watch it just you
know it's not curse the cursed episode
yeah the title sounds like it's talking
about a curse it's not it's talking
about a ghost paranormal law sort of
although that's generally what they call
it right when I went to search warrant
that's usually what it's called it's
what they call it right yeah but yeah so
yeah but this woman going back to the
true crime talking about another serial
killer like I said this this guy has
been recommended for the show like lots
of times and he is like super disgusting
yeah oh yeah Texas Chainsaw Massacre
this is like I was gonna say that this
guy saw the Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
was like that was like his aspirational
man yeah he's like I'm gonna be like a
bigger sleaze than the Sawyer family
yeah from you know what I mean but it's
the same kind of thing like
slaughterhouse type [ __ ] and like [ __ ]
yeah and [ __ ] like that so killing women
on a pig farm yeah it's it was there was
a movie kind of like that back in the
cities used to trick me the hell out
Matt was called what was that Motel hell
oh yeah isn't that the one about the
people that were kind of critters going
what's going fritters fritters yeah yeah
camels and then they buried him up to
their necks yeah you're sticking up had
him out there in the car
like your vegetables grow because
they're grown people because the biology
works yeah whatever it is a fun movie
that we should probably do a [ __ ] yeah
I was just thinking [ __ ] this is episode
hundred forty that's only ten more
episodes until our big 150th episode
which I still so book sales are doing
good yeah yeah and honestly I'm about a
quarter of the way through faceless
villain volume three yeah and I'm also
recording the audio book at the same
time like while I'm writing it right we
got a new microphone I got the new
microphone and everything so I'm sound
so good right now I know our dulcet tone
I know lalala the other ones up there I
don't know what's wrong with it I think
it might be the the plug just the plug I
think that's got to be repaired cuz I
mean if we could fix it then we'd have
to that would be cool right so I'll look
into it yeah you could fix it you
there's they were talking about that
problem and they somebody posted a video
on how to do it I have a solder gun and
I got solder I can get in there and do
it probably well yeah I new one I mean
the thing is like it's no big loss if
you drive because we can't use it now
anyway because I've and $100 100
something dollars microphone there's for
a few cents it might be good you know
good idea right so before we get to all
the serial killing and pig farming and
whatnot
I've got a few shout outs got some new
patrons this week we got a new patron
whose name is Rick it's spelled Rik just
like on The Young Ones
if you guys don't from the early
eighties so thank you very much also our
longtime patron Mary Ellen quadrupled
her support yeah that was like everybody
know we're actually we're over five back
520 ok gate or something like it's
taking a while but it's getting there
you know and honestly like I said it's
like you know it's it's nice to get
but it's like even if you just share the
show with other rifle and stuff like
that like everything helps yeah it all
helps also one of our fans and patrons
Rob Levinson as a filmmaker yeah I
talked to him on messenger some time I
messed with him [ __ ] with him a lot mine
and he is making a movie about 9/11
called where were you yeah so um he's
doing an IndieGoGo for it and I will put
the link in the show notes and
everything like that and I'll probably
put it here in the video too so go and
check that out and help him out it
sounds like a really cool project so you
need to go check that out also I want to
mention this and I just found this out
today we're recording this on a Friday I
just found out today that Lorraine
Warren died she died when yes
I guess it was today or yesterday well
one of our fans like I kind of heard
about for summer but one of our fans
Joni she told us she she told me about
it on Facebook and I was like looking up
I'm like oh my god she finally passed on
you know what that's what we should do
for our hundred fiftieth episode we
should try to contact I'm just kidding
yeah I'm [ __ ] with you Lorraine it's
like I know that like we should on the
Warrens a lot because they seem like
hucksters and everything like that but
she genuinely did seem like a nice lady
yeah and you know she lived a very long
time I think she was 92 yes he's doing
paranormal TV programs yeah yeah not too
many years ago seemed like she'd show up
you know what was that one with the uh
yeah she was on a haunting she was on
paranormal witness she was on all that
[ __ ] she was still making the rounds man
she's gonna cry so and I think she might
have been still maintaining that Museum
that they have that has Annabelle and
all that stuff in it um I so I don't
know like they had kids right and then
John Zaffis is their nephew who's like
that other paranormal investigator right
you know just because the Warrens were
involved with the case doesn't mean the
case was a hoax some of it is they were
involved in some good cases yeah and I
think we might have mentioned that
omission that many times yeah
have gotten flack for bagging on the
Warrens no not the warrants were
involved in some real cases yeah you
know but I think also the the Warrens
exaggerated any case they could get
their hands on you know oh yeah because
they were trying to sell books in
lecture stuff like that which you know I
respect the hospital is a business yeah
I see what you're doing but you know
what I mean it's funny because I think
we don't get um surprisingly big
[ __ ] as we are we don't actually get
that many negative comments but I will
go out on a limb cuz like I said I
usually just go through and delete like
every day that particular episode but
yeah but that episode that we said about
the Warrens that is easily easily the
one we get the most yeah negative
episodes and it's usually just like to
believe yeah and it's always people like
that like well if you guys saw it you
guys it's always that kind of stuff like
we can do shows about all you know what
I mean it's like we did a show about
like a cult Nazis and it's like you know
I don't think I got any negative comedy
than that but we do want about the
Warrens
and everybody loses their [ __ ] losing
this [ __ ] over the warrants it loses
their [ __ ] about demonic possession
right so they're like no it's real
there's there comes a it gets to a
certain you know level to where it's
it's not credible anymore some of the
claims are just too outrageous yeah some
of that stuff they did a werewolf
yeah they got werewolves right up there
with demons with you know demonic
possession I think that you know there
are certain things in poltergeist
phenomenon where the poltergeist focus
exhibits behavior that looks a lot like
demonic possession yeah there's no demon
in there though that's RSPCA it's how
they're interpreting what they see and
because then they can come in all godly
and shed there is a there is a
paranormal but sometimes faith can cloud
your perception of a paranormal you know
you can cloud your perceptions you know
Southern Baptist is gonna see one thing
and then that same event a Muslim might
see it different yeah that's a Jim right
so faith has a lot to do with it right
Medicare psychologist a pair of
psychologists who's an atheist gonna go
now this is something quantum this is
the subconscious mind where I'm kind of
right and that's kind of where I fall
even though technically I'm an atheist
and but I also believe in an afterlife
and I believe in a God but my version of
it is more I would say more like
something ETS star wars with the force
you know yeah like it's not an
intelligent on an intelligent being more
like just some kind of a universal more
like a place like another dimension yeah
I mean well I think the afterlife and
other dimensions and God are all kind of
like the same thing yeah
it's interesting that lorraine warren
just that we just found out today that
lover i just found out today that
Lorraine Warren died because just last
night we went and saw the curse of La
Llorona which was kind of like
indirectly associated at the warrants
cuz it's part of that whole conjuring
universe now I think I said because by
the time this comes out you'll have seen
our matinee episode where we reviewed it
it was all right um and I think in that
I mistakenly said it was directed by
James Wan it was actually produced by
James Wan he gave it to somebody else to
direct he's making movies yeah so that's
why I just wanted to like clear the air
about that because I don't like I said I
don't usually research the movies or
read reviews of him or anything because
I like to come into him without any
preconceptions you know what I mean I
just want to like see it listen okay
movie yeah it was it wasn't great it
wasn't bad man I was scared that thing
was had my hair standing up there the
first half scared it's like yeah it was
a screaming it did not scare that scream
in a net that woman coming at you in
that bridal gown that's cool but then
like halfway through it they kept
showing it too much and then they showed
us his face that's like oh there she is
like nice Ben V from Ludovico
in a dress that's what he said we were
talking about it on the way home for the
movies like does makeup kind of like
that he's a coolican didn't like he's
like it just looks like kicked my ass
next time that's what I mean he hasn't
been out long time so hopefully see I
look like this thing in a dress man well
it'd be a fair fight and I would and I
would videotape we must meet each other
- we were just too tired
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah just get tired of each other yeah
well you know you made your point
yeah both both parties wanna break it
off really yeah we want yeah you can go
tell your friends separately that you
would fight and no it'll like contradict
so it's like whatever it's mutually
assured destruction all right so let's
get into talking about this charming
charming individual known as Roberts
Willie picton probably better known as
Willie picton aka the pig farmer killer
or my very favorite nickname for him
pork chop Rob damn you made that up
know somebody else on the [ __ ]
Wikipedia page chopped Rob yes even
though most people I feel like most
people know him as Willie picked in and
most people called him that I think a
pork chop
Rob that was the name made it for him
after he was found guilty of all these
murders
yeah well because this was another
[ __ ] that had been doing this
for ages before you go before he got
caught it's this is kind of another
thing where it's like what I'm
like 4050 people maybe as many as 70 who
knows and then finally because it was
just prostitutes or just to drug addicts
and so no one gave a whiff of a fart
about it and all the far-right that's
what I mean not even know it wasn't even
no one gave a fart no one even gave a
whiff of a fart the hint of a fart
well they probe that's a transient
population if they come up missing
people don't know where they went right
they're not reliable to begin with
although I mean a lot of them did get
reported missing yeah but but
authorities just think that they skipped
town that's exact wonderful things
running from drug debt yeah and it's
like and it was one of those things were
like years later they go to the property
like search for some other illegal [ __ ]
that he was up to and they're like oh
look at all these [ __ ] body parts
bones they're everywhere right oh ok
this guy I just get into it Lord all
right now most of the things it's
interesting because I think because this
happened in Canada it was in Vancouver
and they have a thing where he still has
a bunch of charges pending this
[ __ ] still alive he saw as a
bunch of charges pending so they have
kind of like a gag thing where they
can't like talk about the case it's
ongoing which I guess they kind of have
here too as well like you're not allowed
to disclose like details and stuff so a
lot of the sites that I've read I want
to like Wikipedia murder pedia like all
the normal places so they're kind of
saying oh well we don't know much about
his childhood or about what he did or
anything like that but then I see this
like hour-long documentary that was on
History Channel or crime Channel or
whatever something and it was about him
and they talked quite a bit about his
childhood so most of the information I
got about its childhood is from that so
if it's inaccurate blamed them not me
I'm just repeating eating some [ __ ] that
they said so now this is what they said
about his childhood now they do know
that he was born in 1949 like I said in
Vancouver now he's born on to his
family's pig farm this is like he's like
third generation pig farmer now even for
pig farm and I'm not [ __ ] on pig
farmers because man pigs are cool
I like pork I like pigs you know just
that they're cool animals yeah farmers
make money they do in this country well
they did in this case too later on but
even if like for pig farmers when they
were kids now the parents the moms name
was Louise and by all accounts she was a
total psycho and also what is that noise
I keep like hearing in the background go
what is that she's on top of the damn
cat tree
she's just like she knows that we're
here talking and we're not talking about
her she's like yeah but yeah so the mom
I don't really know all that much about
the dad but the mom apparently was like
this huge I mean she was like the boss
of the farm and like everybody did what
she said she was just like this crazy
crazy woman and she had like this really
high screechy voice and she was like
always going around like screaming at
everybody
so Willy picton has two siblings once
I'm David and then he has a sister named
Linda now because the sister I guess the
dad was like well the pig farm it's no
place for a girl to grow up so she got
sent away to live with relatives lucky
her because she actually turned up
normal she had like a normal life she
you know she went on married she had
like a normal job and [ __ ] like that she
didn't end up like these her Tirpitz at
this [ __ ] farm okay so now some of
the stories about their youth go thusly
so evidently Willy picton and his
brother David they would go to school
and because they were pig farmers and
apparently on the pig farm they just let
the pigs like live in the house because
that's what you do and they weren't a
big fan of showering so
yeah when they went to school and like I
said this is a fairly rural so a lot of
the kids were farmers I think or you
know were kind of you know they had jobs
in that sort of arena
but even among those people the kids
wouldn't no one would sit by them on the
bus you know they come on the bus and
they had like lions coming off them like
Pigpen you know what I mean yeah that's
where he shower a lot the shower to wake
up a shower to come back and work it
wasn't no joke either yeah because all
the other kids hated them and wouldn't
sit by them called them stinky piggy
yeah you know they'd get on the bus
everybody be like the back and stuff so
like I said it wasn't all for Vancouver
either even though it was like kind of
rural so so it was like a kind of thing
where he gets picked on at school a lot
evidently neither one of them was the
brightest bulb on the Christmas tree you
know if I can put it that way
so they weren't real big fans of school
anyway I believe Willy picked and
dropped out when he was 14 to work on
the farm because he apparently turned
out that he was really really good at UM
dissecting pigs you know yeah I'm like
cutting him up and butchering meat and
stuff like that so there was that whole
thing now there was also a story and
like I said I don't know if this is
entirely true this might have been
something that Willy picked and told you
know the guards at the prison or you
know whoever or said at the trial but he
said when he was growing up he was a
pretty normal kid up until the time that
he went and he bought like a calf that
he was gonna raise and they said he
loved this calf and it was like his pet
and blah-dee-blah
and all this other stuff and then he
comes home from school one day and he's
like hey where's my baby cow like my pet
my best friend cuz he didn't have any
friends because he smelled bad and also
he was kind of weird and Don right so so
he goes and his mom says oh we'll go
look out in the barn and they had
slaughtered his little cow damn so I
don't want to deal yeah so I don't know
if that's true or not I don't know if
his parents just did that to be dicks
no it sounds like a lie to me that's
what I mean so I'm just saying that's
what they were talking about on the
documentary and that was something that
he had said or something somebody else
said about his childhood or whatever
I thought farm families know how to deal
with all that kind of stuff yeah and but
maybe I mean I maybe he was trying to
make it seem like he was like
super-lonely cuz I had sympathy yeah cuz
he didn't have any friends or nothing
like that like it was just him and his
brother farm families you know would buy
something like a calf like that and they
would tell the kids what was gonna
happen you know I mean like well we
don't get attached to this this is food
this is gonna be a veal or or we're
gonna let this cow grow up and when it
gets to a certain size we're gonna we're
gonna turn it into steaks yeah so this
isn't a pet this is work animal you know
that's that's how that goes down I mean
that's that's just the way farming
families are yeah and like I said I
think it's all professional about it you
know they don't they're they don't get
by you know they was doing a pet in a
food animal yeah well I don't know like
I don't know if there was some thing
where he bought this animal as a pet cuz
he was raising it because apparently he
bought it I wouldn't think that a pet so
I don't know well that didn't you say
his mom was an [ __ ] yeah his dad was
probably also an [ __ ] but his mom was
like a bigger [ __ ] so I hear I still
just have a hard time seeing even
[ __ ] parents going out out of their
way to be cruel to an aunt to a kid
behind this an animal that's a pet like
that yeah but it's possible but I mean
yeah where's that raccoon and then he
killed that record right yeah see
there's a callback for the one person on
you we don't know where it is no we do
because we saw one yeah so last night
when we were coming back from the movies
coming into the game and we were coming
in through the gate we were talking to
the the guard who's like a friend of
ours cuz he's like works there at night
all the time movies yeah he's like a
little head peek around a quart little
mask and that's assess it matters a
raccoon right there oh yeah he's coming
to see me yeah he's like cuz I feed him
yeah and I was like what
that's gonna see you he walks right by
it it doesn't even run he goes to his
car opens up the trunk pulls out a bunch
of dog food sets it on the ground pours
it on the ground he's going out there
with his hands he yeah he comes into the
guard shack he hit me on the I was I was
kind of dozing off and he tore watching
TV but he said he hit me on the hit me
on the foot it's like hey buddy man come
on where's our booth well I thought it
was like when I used to work in a
newspaper in Daytona there was like a
little family of Brac hands it was like
a momma and like two or three babies and
they lived out this we had this big huge
[ __ ] giant parking lot and they lived
out there in the woods and like there
was one girl that worked there and she
would always take like pizza crusts and
like other things out there to feed them
so they were used to people coming out
to the parking lot there bagging and
they would come out like on their back
feet with their little hands out I said
they look at little Dickensian orphans
like extended I'm like that is the
cutest [ __ ] ever yeah they're so cute
okay all right so now what we were
saying about his mom Louise being an
[ __ ] now as I said take this with a
grain of salt also but listen to this
[ __ ]
this was another story from their youth
or their teenage years or whatever that
I saw in this documentary so um Willy's
brother David he gets like to be 15 or
16 and he gets his learner's permit or
his driver's license so he's out tooling
around like a teenage boy is gonna do
and he's not really that experienced a
driver as a teenage boy is not he hits a
kid that's either like riding a bike or
walking on the side of the road I don't
think he hit him on purpose all that was
possible but so he hits the kid the kids
like flies on something and they're like
oh [ __ ] so he's all busted up and [ __ ]
up and everything so they drive back to
the farm and they tell their mom hey I
just hit this kid with a car and she's
like don't worry about it I'll take care
of it she goes back she rolls the kid
into a ditch that is filled with water
now the kid was still alive at this
stage even though he was all [ __ ] up
and everything and he might have lived
if she hadn't rolled him into this test
full of water any
[ __ ] they find the body yes so this
probably did happen yes so they know the
body that's yeah talking about okay but
they imeem evidently they got the body
picked up according to this documentary
they picked the body up then everything
but no charges were ever brought because
they still ruled it an accident right
even though the kid would probably still
be because he died of drowning so he was
still alive after the car hit him yeah
but they didn't know the momma brought
him in there until later yeah I guess
yeah they just found she's just like
yeah I'll take care of it right and that
kid was probably Wow so that's so that's
plausible it's plausible that that
happened that's because there was a body
associated with that story yeah unless
he knew about that case and then made up
a story about his mom doing it yeah
there's no way in knowing no I'm like I
said there's not a huge amount of
information we're because there's not
like a huge amount of information about
this [ __ ] dude right and like I said
I think it's because there's a lot of
cases still pending against him so they
so they don't want like a lot of
information but I'm getting out of
nothing like that
Canada man well yeah I mean but this
documentary apparently found out all
this stuff about him so I don't know and
and there's videos of him like talking
like confessions and there's like a PDFs
of his confessions and [ __ ] like that so
now when Willy picked in and his brother
David and the sister Linda when they get
older their parents die as they do and
they all have the farm left to them now
Linda like I said she had never been on
the farm because she grew up with
relatives issues just kind of like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm out of here and she went
off to have a normal life really Willie
was the only one that was into the farm
thing although David hung around too he
was a little bit more popular with women
and stuff than Willie was so maybe he
actually showered once in a while and
stuff but here's the fascinating thing
in the 90s they decided well you know
this is too much farm just for two guys
or whatever so they started so they
wanted to sell part of the farm off not
all of it so it was like a pretty big
I'm gonna have 13 acres for teenager or
something like that it was like a fairly
so they sell some of it
off now figures I've seen for what they
got for this property are somewhere
between two and five and a half million
dollars well damn yeah well damn
Canadian are US dollars I think Canadian
still it's still law at the time yeah it
was a [ __ ] ton of money now that's
enough to turn any life around right but
think of who you're talkin right yeah
because here's the thing right now
honored that [ __ ] well they do but they
did yeah um but the thing about it is
that apparently like I said Willy picton
he stunk he was stupid it's like so he
couldn't get laid like legitimately
right so when he gets all this money
he's like to change prostitutes right so
he starts like hiring prostitutes and
then you know and then it just escalates
from there well like he would like buy
them drugs he would give them money like
and these are Walker yeah well where he
got most of the we're not talking about
the $1500 a night call girl we're
talking about $30 a pop streetwalker if
that yeah I mean this is theirs that was
what a level he was at yeah even though
he was technically I mean now a
millionaire so but that was how he
decided to use his money he's like I'm
just gonna like shower you know I'm
gonna make it rain for these street
hookers right ya know which [ __ ] man
they just wanted drugs and money and
they were like what he stinks and [ __ ]
but he's got money so that's fine and
most of them like the ones that survived
anyway um said that he was like a pretty
nice dude which I always thought was
kind of strange except for when he
wasn't killing people yeah exactly that
so so this whole thing where so he has
all this money and all this other kind
of crap now in 1997 he picked up
prostitutes from this area it's this
notorious neighborhood in Vancouver it
is the poorest neighborhood in all of
Canada
and has highest HIV rates everything
they said basically it's just like
really really dangerous it's only like a
ten block area but it means it may not
even be there anymore well I don't know
if it is I mean everything that I saw
was from a couple years ago and they
have been talking about what's still
there never so it might still be there
because Detroit you know I lived in
Detroit for about a year and said the
worst parts of Detroit now are gone
they've just been bulldozed yeah and you
know a lot of it was just left yeah they
died off generations weren't replaced
they just yeah this is just an area
where you know it's just prostitutes and
drug addicts just like walking around
everywhere and [ __ ] so that was where
it's called the low track that's kind of
its nickname so that's where he would go
to get prostitutes now he picked up this
one girl whose name was Wendy I stutter
and he brings her back to the house and
according to her he put um because he
was into bondage I guess so he puts
handcuffs on her and she does not like
that so she's trying to get out of the
handcuffs and then he starts to try to
stab her damn she gets the knife away
from him and stabbed him back now one of
the things I saw said that she slashed
his throat I don't know she slashed his
throat or if she just stabbed in the
stomach or whatever and then she got the
[ __ ] out of there she like runs off the
farm she Flags down a car handcuffed in
the front yeah and she just had the
handcuffs on when she escaped yeah okay
um so she Flags in a car the car takes
her to the hospitai um I couldn't really
tell from the pictures he just looks
like he looks like a little scrawny bald
scumbag okay like he might be tall I
don't know but we're not talking about a
physically imposing kind of guy well are
they ever I mean right no sometimes they
are or you would think they kind of are
I mean serial killers a lot of regular
just like little wormy look at it I
think we mentioned that before and he's
the wormy is like he really looks like a
sleaze like sometimes reality and movie
kind of blur together about Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and I'm thinking of
that dude that big motel hell they got
the damn pig mask on and the chainsaw
and then remember that yeah yeah this
guy does not look like that I mean he
basically looks like he just he looks
like some weird creepy carnival worker
where it's like you saw if you saw him
like across the street you'd like cross
the street be like yeah I mean like not
he's not very yeah he just looks like a
dirtbag like some homeless dude that
gets on the bus and okay stinks and you
like right I mean looks like that so
were the millions of dollars it is yeah
and he's got like millions of dollars so
now Wendy like I said she gets away for
she stabs his ass and she gets away from
him and she goes she gets a car you know
she gets somebody to give her a ride to
the hospital now she gets to the
hospital and they're fixing her up or
whatever and then willy picton who was
also who has also been stabbed he goes
to the same hospital to get fixed up now
the doctors at this point she's like
well she has handcuffs on and willy
picton has a handcuff key in his pocket
I wonder if these two cases are related
right so they take the key from his
pocket and unlock her handcuffs right
now it kind of sucks because he kind of
got away with this like he did get
arrested for attempted murder or sexual
assault or whatever it was and she would
not testify because she was scared that
he would kill her I don't understand
that you can't kill a [ __ ] from
behind bars
yeah but if he didn't get out like I can
understand that and also she thought
that he wouldn't get convicted or he
would but he had enough money to post
bond that's it right and it's like you
know she you know where she didn't have
anywhere to go she couldn't like hide or
nothing like that um so she declined to
press charges so he was let go yeah
now at this stage that was in the
beginning of his career all this [ __ ] as
far as they know
I mean he might have killed people
before that but I'm not really sure
because they they never have established
this is another [ __ ] that they'd have
never established established how many
people he killed just because the nature
of the victim yeah well one the nature
of the victim to what he did with the
bodies like most of them he would cut
them up or he would grind them up in a
you know a stump grinder or he would
feed them to pigs sometimes but you know
that they know of it's like so they have
no idea I'm in a pig feed then sell the
pigs yet they have no idea like how many
people he killed you know what I mean
they don't they don't have like any
proof because mostly what they found was
just like body parts and [ __ ] Wow
so this part kind of cracks me up so
Willie and his brother David they take
some of their money and they take like
one of the slaughterhouse like I have
some pictures of you know like the
search of the property Oh what are you
doing she's waking up she hid the camera
with her body she's like what that's not
where I wanted it okay good right thank
you are you gonna do it again
don't move it okay good girl so they
take one of the slaughterhouses and they
convert it into how can I put this it's
kind of like an entertainment it's like
kind of Center baby so it's called
you're gonna love this it's called the
piggie palace good times Society okay
yeah so this is so they house is now a
community center yeah so they
essentially started a company like an
event they called it like an event
planning company or something like that
their stated goal was and I quote to
organize coordinate manage and operate
special events functions dances shows
and exhibitions on behalf of service
organizations sports organizations and
other worthy groups man that's all
gobbledygook yeah so this is something
that they've started but what it really
was was just a way to have these big
huge party
he's where hookers could come and bikers
could come and like drug dealers could
come there and they could have these big
huge parties and did they come yeah okay
um yeah they said some of their parties
like I think when they had their New
Year's Eve party like in 1998 or
something like that they like 2000
people show up or [ __ ] like that didn't
stink to how to happen it's a pig see
now this is why I have so many questions
I have so many questions
yeah one um okay I don't even know where
to start so I know this is maybe like
rural Vancouver and stuff but seriously
do you really not have anything better
to do then go to a place called the
piggy palace
yeah good time Society and hang out with
a bunch of people who sleep around pigs
and don't bathe themselves I got four
motorcycles three of them I built myself
actually all four of them the other the
fourth one isn't done I would never go
to a damn pig farm to go party never
that's what I mean why would you I have
to kind of question I passed by that old
biker hangout Cabbage Patch one time I
went man that place is a good dump I
think it is a dump
it's a [ __ ] dump I'm from this town
it is I wouldn't stop there but for
whatever reason like every time it was
all backed up they had advanced plan
maybe I would go to catch bad they do
but it's that's the thing like by God
dog stand it does it's very very small
and I wonder if people that come to
Daytona because like I said I'm from
there is more there I wonder if people
that come there for Bike Week or
Biketoberfest or whatever if they go oh
the famous Cabbage Patch it's like this
dinky little shack yeah there had to be
topless girls there before Einstein
there are well there's mud wrestling
corny between cream corn recipe we know
but yeah well they they kind of just set
up the whole outside like they set up a
big outdoor stage and stuff and there so
there is no jelly indoor there is no end
I mean from what if you drive past it in
the other time of the year it just looks
like a tiny little tiny little wooden
shack with a big huge like parking like
dirty parking and there's like a farm
out behind it yeah some alien horn oh
[ __ ] man she I think she hung out there
seems I don't remember it was Cabbage
Patch or maybe what the [ __ ] was that
other place called I don't remember it
was someplace that I've I've never been
there but I've driven pants
they have Daytona Bike Week all-time up
the road have I ever been any room line
every now well it's I don't come I'm a
local I live here
yeah it's very different when you live
here yeah it's seriously like I said I
grew up my whole life in Daytona it's
really not fun it's like Bike Week is
Bike Week was better than Spring Break
Spring Break socked yeah the traffic was
so bad you couldn't get because I used
to live like on the beach side cuz
there's two there's mainland their
speech side I just live on the beach
side you couldn't get [ __ ] anywhere
yeah you had to leave like three hours
yeah everybody's like peeing on your
porch and bikers and motorcyclists that
are from this area man named red Bike
Week Conda they kind of dread it they
don't go to that all the locals are
stepping on our turf
yeah it's that kind of yeah and I've
heard that my whole life like real
bikers are just like man they all come
there and they're like brand-new like
biker costumes yeah so I did hear a lot
of people like complaining about that
and like I said it's gotten so big and
so big it's like they get like [ __ ]
half a million people and you know
Daytona is a relatively large town but
it's not really it can't really
accommodate that many yeah I've had
friends from the fuel scene you do
you're gonna be the bike are you gonna
be go up to Daytona Bike Week we're
gonna be up there yeah the turbo Buell
and erica's East Turbo Buell is gonna be
up there you gonna come in now man oh my
god oh you're not going it's all guys
from out of town go yeah they come
around about that you know one thing
that is neat in Daytona though is like
the weekend before or the weekend after
Thanksgiving they do turkey rod and
that's all the like old-fashioned cars
like people have done like all their
really cool car
and you can go it's at the speedway and
you can kind of go look at it our
motorcycles one of these days I'll make
a motorcycle video wait I can insert it
in the middle yeah so so yeah people are
hanging out at the piggy balance good
time Society come in they're hanging out
with the scumbag can you have a piece of
when you have a chunk of change that big
you're an idiot if you haven't doubled
that [ __ ] it takes money to make money
he isn't it again you should be able to
make a bunch of money with that four or
five million dollars yeah you should be
able to do just a proper real estate
investment just buying the right house
you can make a lot of money on that yeah
like I said this guy I'm at yeah well
I'm not [ __ ] on farm people but as I
said it was the wrong one though
yeah it's like this guy just seems like
a total sleaze it's like all he cared
about was getting you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's like all he cared about
it he's like no one would [ __ ] him
voluntarily oh that money money had to
be offense so you crack had to be a fact
yes so he had to offer them money or
drugs or rape them that was like all and
I guess that's how he looked at it you
had five million dollars do you think
that you might just be who view take a
shower and then if you had some new
clothes
cut yeah maybe even would get a facelift
go to the gym you know it's not like he
lived in the middle of the [ __ ]
Ozarks all right Antarctica or anything
like that he lived in Vancouver it's a
big city yeah it's you know I mean it's
a blowing city but right but I mean
there's [ __ ] there yeah yeah it's funny
because I was just watching this video
today um this girl that was doing I came
her than ever channel is but she had
done like a 15 or 16 minute video about
this case and she was from she's from
there so she said that as part of her
project she was like a criminology major
and she went out to the
the property where the picton farm used
to be it's gone it they tore all the
buildings down so it's just like you
still can't go on there because the
government seized it because they don't
know if there's like other [ __ ] on there
that they haven't found yet right um she
says oh it's just got a big fence around
it but she's like it's weird because
you'd think of it as like this very
rural like out in the middle of nowhere
and [ __ ] like that but she's like
nowadays it's like yeah here's this
fenced off piece of land there's like a
[ __ ] Walmart there's like finest [ __ ]
around there so you know yeah it's just
kind of weird to think about like even
when I was looking at the pictures of it
it doesn't look like it's that far out
in the middle of nowhere and that's the
thing it's you know he lived on a pig
farm he did it was a working pig farm
they actually had pigs they slaughtered
the pigs they sold the meat they took
the fat and stuff too like the rendering
plant nearby that they made other [ __ ]
out of it so it's not like it was just
this [ __ ] in the middle of nowhere
and like I said you know when they
opened up the piggy palace you know
thousands of people came to these
[ __ ] parties that they had so
apparently the parties are pretty
[ __ ] epic I guess they had some
really really really good drugs how good
was the drugs act that they would really
have to be so I don't know it's for me
to go out there I would never that's
what I mean it's like cool
this just seems like you know it just
seems like the in Daytona ifs I grew up
in Daytona and the the hottest nightclub
in Daytona this will tell you when I was
growing up it's called the rock and
ranch yeah bad and it's just this big
country-western bar people think of
Daytona they think it's gonna be like
this big international City man that's
redneck [ __ ]
it is Daytona's redneck it's better than
it wasn't it's not it's not far from
here and just it's just like what 30
miles of it maybe 35 30 miles up the
street but Orlando's like it's a totally
different scene in Orlando in Orlando
isn't even that big a city I mean no but
it's a lot more sophisticated than that
it is and you don't have the problems
that you would have Lexi in Miami yeah I
like Orlando it's a good it's a happy
medium yeah it's not so huge that you
have like all these problems and yeah
and honestly the you know we got
yeah there's good clubs here there's
good night there's actually good club
downtown
yes you know there's like cool clubs
there's the Enzian theater that shows
like really cool like indie movies and
old movies and stuff and yeah so we have
cool [ __ ] we have some cool museums or
cool Science Museum for example scoffs
clubs here yes there's all kind of good
[ __ ] going on yeah so so all right piggy
Palace
yeah um actually let's take a break
because we're already like we're gonna
get to this case we got to talk about
these crimes I mean we are gonna talk
all right but we are gonna yeah holy
[ __ ] we're having our own piggy back in
a week yeah cuz remember how I said last
week it's like I had to back off yeah
because of all the stuff they told you
about the numerators yeah trying to
manipulate what I do they're trying to
try they're trying to restrict my
greatness no they're trying to quit
they're trying to bother me about blood
pressure and triglycerides and [ __ ]
was they what they called liver enzymes
yeah liver enzymes okay your liver
enzyme I was I did that blood test I was
hungover when I did that blood test
that's the Limbourg liver enzymes it
they said did you eat it did you eat
today now I need today oh we didn't do
the blood work then and I was they
didn't ask you've had just published if
I was hungover we're thinking oh it's
like whenever they do blood trucks whose
blood test particularly like lipid
profile and stuff like that they're
supposed to tell you ahead of time hey
don't eat for 12 I think it's 12 hours 8
to 12 hours that's what they used to
tell me all the time because I used to
always get my cholesterol tested what I
had insurance but so that so if you eat
like in that time period then it'll [ __ ]
up your it'll make you look like you
have whele way worse cholesterol than
you actually or so they say so they're
trying to get you to not eat but yeah
they didn't ask if you yeah it's head
trunk that I yeah
all right so I'm we're gonna take a
break right now
and then we'll come back and talk some
more about this charming [ __ ]
the pig farmer killer I just I want to
call him porkchop Rob that works out Rob
because that's I don't know it's it's so
cute see and that's just appeals to my
[ __ ] up sense of humor but yeah so
we'll be back in just a minute talking
about Robert Willy the faceless villain
a collection of the eeriest unsolved
murders of the 20th century volume 2
includes cases spanning the years from
1960 through 1979 featuring such
infamous crimes as the triple homicide
at Lake Bodom the family massacre known
as the good heart murders the serial
killings of the Zodiac Bible John Jack
the stripper and the freeway phantom the
slaughter of dozens of women and girls
along the highway of tears and the Texas
killing fields and the mysterious death
of suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format you can run what are you doing
what you dealing I know it's crazy admit
I know it's insane say something for it
you hanging out yeah what's up with the
tail what's up with that - what you
doing hmm
hey so big though
hey man yeah
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back for part two we're
talking about Willie picked in the pig
farmer killer aka porkchop Rob because I
just like saying yeah we're talking
about this come back while you're doing
your commute or doing your chores at
home or doing your tedious drudgery work
that you have to do to make that damn
paycheck I notice like I used to have
jobs like that before I became the big
cheese do you want to know is really
funny too it's that we're talking about
the pig farmer killer and during the
break we're actually slow we didn't do
that on purpose
turn that burner up full we would we
would Sam's Club and they were given
those Oscar Mayer wiener 'aa way yeah we
were like we can't and they were like
impacts of five so back in the old days
you have to like buy a pack of fifteen
you to open them have to eat them all
poor to go bad yeah now they're like now
they're in these small packs of five in
the big old damn box and what would they
want like five dollars and something
cents for them for that whole [ __ ]
huge box we're gonna get I'm gonna put
that on the menu so what I did is I got
a pan and I get blue and I put some oil
in it and I heated it all the way up
through five of them in there Browns
them real quick and then covered it and
turned it on low very low which is like
warm okay yeah I'm just letting sit
there for the rest of the show yeah slow
cooked all the way through like a
rotisserie hot dog gourmet from 7-eleven
7-eleven want to just spin on that damn
rag yeah I've heard they are specially
if they people that work there an
inattentive and they leave him on there
for too long and they might have been on
there for like 24 to 26 hours just
sitting there it that's constant
temperature yeah man that's like the
American version of the damn gyro meat
with that you that Greek where they call
this just like that delicacy that's
almost as good sausage Oh God
nevermind say my dad Vienna sausage is
almost air I think it's the main
ingredient yeah they smell so bad you
might come in they get huge like a
marshmallow my dad it's like now every
time I'm in because they still sell it
because people buy them yeah and they
come in flavors now spam spam is good
you go you're busting on spam if you
know to do a [ __ ] loves man you got
to slice it thin you got to fry
it's good with eggs eggs you got to do
with it man the Hawaiians love that [ __ ]
you put it with everything they have
different flavors of spam now and it's
not cheap like it was and you put it in
ramen before oh it's good and that was
actually quite the Japanese put it in
ramen yeah that was actually really good
know what to do with this although I
like it it's salty it's it's got Bryant
it's very so if you slice it thin and
you cook it the right way you can get
some s salt out of it yeah but it's a
good breakfast meat look like eggs and
like you make a salmon I like it mixed
with something because it's like right I
like I like salty [ __ ] but that is like
even too salty
the world war ii army the army infantry
okay huntin first airborne which was
spam powered that's what they were
issued that's another shirt right there
I'm sorry powered the victory that is
America that made America global player
with spam spam was the energy that did
it it was like some shadow fall out they
ain't fall out it's like fallout three
fallout 4 that's got not that's not good
for two British I don't watch in my
pythons the two British in to effeminate
everybody okay
now speaking of pork products so let's
get back to the pig farm now here's the
interesting thing about cuz I just can't
get I can't get tired of saying piggy
good time society sir whoo let's go to
the piggy palace good time to turn time
I would slap that man for that well he
deserves to be slapped for other things
what we did this would be like the 550
million thing that you yeah that's way
down the list
piggy path so I forgot to mention that
when they first started this little
enterprise that they actually registered
it as a charity which I guess they were
allowed to do for a little while until
the Canadian government Canada it's like
you guys are just having like raves and
biker parties with hookers and blow
and so no and they took their like
tax-exempt status away or whatever it
was and if they also told them no more
parties at this [ __ ] site
because this is clearly not what you
said so they did like get caught for
that but then you know like I said they
have a New Year's party anyway they're
just like [ __ ] you now
all through this time period there's
this guy and he's apparently working in
the farm I don't know if he lives on the
farm where he works there his name is
like Bill Hiscox or something like that
and he starts to notice he's like you
know all these um sex workers keep
coming onto this farm and then I don't
see them ever again and that's a little
weird
he also noticed that Willy picton had a
lot of illegal firearms so it was either
this is this is this is Canada I'm not
sure what illegal firearms there were
you can but you can't own any kind of
pistol mmm yeah I'm not really sure
maybe some Canadians could tell I don't
know what all he had on there because he
did find some [ __ ] but well here the
problem is what ended up happening it
was either bill Hiscox or some anonymous
person that had been to one of the piggy
palace parties said hey he's got all
these illegal weaponry which must have
been like pretty egregious for somebody
to like [ __ ] notice it was so they
like called the cops and they said he's
got all these illegal weapons so the
cops get a warrant and they go there so
look
or illegal weapons this is in 2002 now
all the search warrant was for us for
illegal weapons they start looking on
there and then while they're looking
around they don't find that many illegal
weapons but then they find like it was
either a mattress and or a piece of
carpet that had a lot of blood on it
mm-hmm
also they found a asthma inhaler that
had a prescription thing on it for a
girl who had been reported missing right
so they thought that was a little
strange so they're like okay well they
can't you know cuz you it's just like
the u.s. if you have a search warrant
for a particular thing if you find other
things then you have to go back and get
another search warrant for that thing so
they're like well okay we don't give a
[ __ ] about the illegal weapons anymore
but now we think some shits been like
people have been murdered on here so
let's get a search warrant for that so
they went back and did that now it's sad
like I said and we talked about this a
little bit on our highway of tears show
we talked about this on like it anywhere
where a serial killer and I didn't you
know serial killers know this [ __ ] this
is why they target you know people who
were hitchhiking or people who are
prostitutes or something she's like oh
no one's gonna look for them and [ __ ]
like that now people were looking for
them um in the documentary that I
watched there was a woman who she was
running like a community center for you
know prostitutes to come there and like
get food and a place to sleep and like
medical care and stuff and she's like
you know I knew a lot of these girls and
I noticed that a lot of them were going
missing and I reported a lot of them
missing so there were you know missing
persons files with the police but the
police didn't really care she's like you
know the police were like oh well you
know they're drug addicts they're sex
workers they wander around it's like who
knows where they went but they know
there's something to that though right
think about your five-year-old little
daughter doesn't go anywhere when she's
missing that's high priority okay yeah
23 year old hooker that no shows up to
your town you don't know where she came
from
you don't even know her family she's
there for a few weeks and then you
see her anymore you know I mean yeah who
do you tell yeah you know what do you do
about that you say hey there was this
girl here we don't really know where she
came from
yeah I was here for two or three weeks
and now she's gone
that's not the problem they're like well
so what yeah she you know she wasn't
from here to begin with she maybe she
went back home yeah woman that's what
they thought so you know I mean but
they're worse it's totally
understandable but there were so many of
them in this one area that people were
starting to notice there was a time girl
where's that girl where's that girl like
they were all here and then they were
all gone when I got out of high school
in Brazil and came back to the United
States and went to Detroit all right and
before I went to the service I hopped
around in a couple different places in
Detroit in a very short period of time
if I'd gone missing during that time
nobody would know where the hell I'd
been or you know I mean or if I had
skipped out on a lease you know I mean a
landlord would say that there was this
guy I'm not really sure where he was
from and now he's gone yeah you know I
mean they wouldn't know true well some
of these girls live their whole lives
like that yeah so you have to look at it
in that way well and it's interesting
too because I was just like I said I've
been working on faceless villain three
and I was doing the audio book so I've
been editing some of the audio and it's
interesting to me like a couple of the
people that got cuz there's like an
alarming number and I couldn't even put
them all in the book but there's an
alarming number of girls you know
teenage girls that are just they're not
even like prostitutes they just like are
like oh I'm gonna go to California and
like you know hang out with the hippies
or whatever and then they go and like
hitchhike and then they're never heard
from again
right and then sometimes their families
don't necessarily report them missing
because they just think they're out
there so she's like oh they're just out
there like live in their life and
they'll get in touch with me and stuff
and I think that happened so but then
they get murdered at some point and then
they don't know who they are and like
IRAs sinking of this one that was named
her name was Marsha King they called her
buckskin girl for a long time because
when they found her just on the side of
the road in [ __ ] Arizona or Texas or
something like that and she was wearing
like this poncho that looked like
someone had handmade it
like it was you know what I mean it was
like really fancy so they called her
that and they didn't identify her for
like 38 years yeah and then later on
they found it and like they got in touch
with their family and they're like you
know she was just you know she was she's
out like living her life and like she
was maybe hitch or whatever it was like
the the mom she's like I stayed in the
same house and I had the same phone
number in case she wanted to come back
yeah but you can't you can't really
disparage the cops and the local
authorities there's a lot of people
coming and going
most of them are alright nothing ever
happened to them it's hard to tell the
living ones from the dead because you
don't have a body yeah and then you can
go on unsolved mysteries I remember I
saw one were they found a dead girl in a
locker yeah an abandoned building
somewhere and she had black hair and
moccasins and they don't know who the
hell she is yeah like there's a lot yeah
I mean there's a lot of that just some
girl in her late teens early 20s with
damn moccasins with beads on it they
thought she might have been some kind of
an Indian I'm Native American girls
because she had black hair and those
moccasins and for this to this day I
don't think anybody knew who'd know
who's that and there's a lot of those
and honestly we were talking about this
the other day and I said you know in
some ways because I write about so many
of these cases it's like it makes me
want to just like go on a web salute and
see if I could like solve some of this
[ __ ] cuz it bothers me it really bothers
me they're like all of these girls like
all these teenage girls it's like they
just wanna meet it ran away from home or
you know or something like that or some
of them didn't run away from home they
were just like hitchhiking to their
friend's house or something like that
and they just disappeared yeah and then
later they find all these bodies just
thrown on the side of the road or they
don't even know that this girl I was
talking about they found her like that
mid late 80s
yeah and if you wanna and it makes you
want makes you wonder by what process
does a person become so forgotten that
when they when they die and are murdered
and they find the body
no one even claims the body see that's
that what process what process has to
happen for that to happen because I've
written about a lot of cases like that
where they found a body like I don't
know that is it's usually just on the
side of the road now they do um if they
push they'll still investigate [ __ ]
they'll reopen it like every few years
and see if they can match stuff up and
people on life web sleuths or something
like some internet forum sometimes will
make a match up and be like hey look
into this it's like this girl looks like
that girl that you know was reported
missing like you know 30 40 years ago
and sometimes they'll match it up but I
want I kind of want to get involved in
that because it really really bothers me
like all of these and like thanks maybe
your next book after this one would be
something about that yeah because
there's it just bothered me that there
were so many jane doe's and john doe's
that have never been identified back in
the 60s the 70s and they still don't
know who that is right and it's like and
sometimes it's because like in the case
of Marcia King her family loved her and
they thought she was still alive
somewhere they just figured oh she's out
living her life and it's fine but she
had died like only a few months after
leaving home and they didn't know all
this time and it's like they only knew
like 38 years later yeah anything goes
on long enough than the family members
all died all right and it's like a lot
of them do and this it bothers me so
much yeah but a lot the thing about this
though even though a lot of these women
were drug addicts and they were
prostitutes and stuff they had families
that were looking for them they had
people that worked at the social center
that you know noticed that they were
gone or like a bunch of them were gone
also the dude that worked at the farm
was like you know I see these girls like
turn up and then I don't see them again
so what is happening to them so there
were people looking for these people
even though it was a you know an
inherently transient population so as I
said they found some possessions and
some like an alarming amount of blood on
this farm while they were looking for
other [ __ ] so they go back and they get
another search warrant and then they
come back and start looking for [ __ ] now
all of the stuff they found at the farm
like I said they still do not know how
many people this [ __ ] killed so
here's some of the [ __ ] they found on
this [ __ ] farm
so there are skulls that are like cut in
half like with one of those like big
those
like circular saws that they used to
like cut you know yeah Pegasus okay
yeah because he had a slaughterhouse he
was a big farmer so there were skulls
that were cut in half and then inside
the skulls that were like cut off hands
nose girl feet and stuff yeah there was
[ __ ] like that
I mean they cut the skull in half now
put the hands and the feet in the skull
yeah okay like [ __ ] like that okay um
you know they they just found all kinds
of like bloody clothes the identifying
pieces and put them all into one area
yeah and that you know they found and it
was just like all over the place like
everywhere that he looked so you know
they found buckets there's like [ __ ] in
the freezer there's like body parts and
if it's like heads and skulls they found
like the one guy on the [ __ ]
documentary was like we found this
bucket and I'm like I'm glad I don't
have your job man but he's like this
bucket and it's just like there's
[ __ ] skulls like hair on it just in
this pink soup
it was just like [ __ ] yeah it was
like that and I was like oh my god so
just like this [ __ ] they found around
this farm was just like horrifying this
is the teeth jaw bones skulls bones skin
everywhere and the shitty thing about it
is that okay like I said they're not
entirely sure what this guy did with all
these victims but they think that he
would put them up in the slaughterhouse
just like a pig he would cut them in
half they think that he would grind them
up in like the wood chipper and feed
them to the pigs
or this is one thing they were kind of
afraid that had happened was that
because he sold pork yeah and because he
took [ __ ] to the rendering plant like
all the time yeah they are not sure
where a lot of that stuff ended up so
they had to put out like a media thing
and it's like hey if you bought pork
from this guy or you bought any like
pork products from this area you might
have eaten a human you might have eaten
like someone you know like a relative
why did they tell him that that well
because they want they wanted to do a
recall they were just FYI so like I said
there
looking around this farm they're [ __ ]
just fine in bones and teeth and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that belongs to missing people like
all over the place they find this is
super special and many sources have
named this they find a 22 revolver with
a dildo attached to the barrel now later
on when they tested the DNA on this the
DNA had Willy Pickton's DNA and on it
and also a woman who had been reported
missing he said that he was using the
dildo as a silencer on the pistol okay
no so there was a bullet there's a
bullet hole through it I don't know good
because the first thing I thought of
when I thought of pistol with a dildo on
the end could happen somebody pulled
right that's what I was thinking so I
kind of feel like maybe he was doing
that and didn't want to say that I don't
know did you see how many shame that's
kind of what like if he did do that
would he admit it no I don't know he
might be too stupid to like think I just
want to note that has anybody seen what
this unit were there any witnesses to
what he was doing well as I was saying
before there was a woman now according
to the documentary that I watched there
was a woman on camera but her name is
but she was a friend of his now he never
killed her obviously for whatever reason
but she used to come to the farm all the
time for drugs and whatnot
now she later claimed according to this
documentary that she either passed out
or fell asleep at some party at his
house and then woke up and then went out
to the slaughterhouse and she saw Willy
picton and there was a woman like
hanging in the slaughterhouse like he
like she saw like the woman's feet like
which had purple nail polish on it and
he was like cutting her in half or
something like you would a pig so but
apparently she never said anything until
later I think she testified against him
at the trial but I don't think she said
anything about it at the time
now see what was happening
was that because so many of these like
sex workers and stuff were going missing
it was starting to get around on the low
track that hey don't go with this guy
because we think something fishy is
going on like you know what I mean
they're not like stupid they see like a
lot of their friends disappearing and
they're like you know the last person
they were seen with was this dirtbag
with all the money and the drugs so
maybe don't go with that guy so what he
started doing after that was that
because he had a female friend he would
have that friend allegedly um
go and bring girls to him right because
he was getting to a point where people
are starting to recognize him and
starting to feel like you know this guy
was the last guy that all these girls
were seen with and now they're gone so
they were starting to think something
was up so he started like recruiting
female friends to go and get victims for
him so what's his MO I mean he sits up
in his pig farm yeah and he goes to
where the hookers are first
yeah and brings hookers back to his
place he was doing that for a while like
I said because he had he had a lot of
money okay
so he would go and some of the
prostitutes that lived would later say
oh he seems like a nice dude he's got a
lot of money he's got good drawers so he
was a repeat customer to service so that
means he would go and get certain
hookers and bring them back to his place
and then let him go over and over again
but some hookers he killed yes then
later on II have another girl go out
there and go get him
yeah after it started getting like
people started to recognize that he was
the last guy that a lot of these hours
has been seen with and a lot and then
like their friends noticed that they
were no not there anymore
does anybody have any idea like why he
would kill some and not others I mean is
there a story here I don't really know
it's it just seems like this one woman
in particular and I wish I could
remember what her name was because she I
don't think they talked to her in the
documentary they're talking about her
but I feel like she probably knew that
he was doing that [ __ ] but I don't know
if she was like afraid of him or if she
thought no one would believe her or what
and like how did he kill him do they
know the how what the means he had a lot
of guns so I'm assuming that he shot
them
you'd probably either shot them or
strangled them that's usually what they
do and then as I said they don't have a
lot of details about this they only know
what they can surmise from all of the
body parts was he found on the farm
couldn't been about sex cuz he was
kidding sex already they were
prostitutes and he had money well must
have been it had some dues bondage where
what was he'd like to do but we don't
know he yeah torture or was it just
execute seems like he got off on like
once he you know could pay prostitutes
and they would do it every so like it
seemed like he was almost getting off on
like the escalation like a lot of serial
killers do it's like you know oh well I
can get sex from a woman cuz I can pay
her but you know then it kind of
escalates to rape then it escalates to
now I'm gonna cut her up like a pig um
some of the people in the documentary
speculated that he seemed to just see
them just see these women as as he would
a pig just like an animal that he could
do with what he wanted and then he could
just get rid of it
makes me makes me wonder was this
[ __ ] having sex with pigs uh it
wouldn't shock me yeah it seems like
weird because I usually just cross over
about women and pigs away yeah if women
are pigs are pigs women does that yeah
because I mean you have to think to that
like this this guy grew up his whole
family from like a little kid from
everything I've read was like this whole
pig farm like they just let the pigs
like run through the house and it's like
they weren't they had there was no
separation between the human and the
animal so it would not say bin yeah
maybe we're not shocked at all if he was
also into bestiality he seems like that
type of guy you know
I'm chilly right allegedly don't sue me
like this guy's gonna sue me yes lawyer
saying he's a pig [ __ ] yeah he so as I
said you know at first they go for the
illegal weapons thing and then they come
back because they find some other things
so he's um eventually arrested on
February 22nd of 2002
now they first charged him with two
counts of first degree murder because
that was those were like the strongest
cases of like what they they found some
of the people's stuff it's like they
found blood that they determined
probably belonged to these victims so
those were their two strongest cases
these were Serina ibattz way and Mona
Wilson those were the first two murders
that he was charged with now what they
decided to do because they weren't
really getting anywhere when they were
interviewing him so they thought well
they suspected at this point that he was
probably a serial killer and that he
wasn't all that bright so they said what
we're gonna do is we're gonna put him in
this cell and we're gonna put him in a
cell with an undercover cop who was
pretending to be another murderer and
see if he yaps because they're like he
seems like the type of dude that would
want to brag about how many people he
killed
now you have to imagine at this point
they have only just arrested him they've
only charged him with two um they think
that he's killed a lot more but they're
not sure how many because there's just
like parts and DNA and bloods just all
over this farm and you know just like
[ __ ] corpse soup and whatever so they
put him in this cell with an undercover
officer now what he sends to the
undercover officer is that she's acting
crazy what are you doing
being crazy get on to show Pookie look
at her you're just tearing everything up
so they put him in the cell with the
undercover officer and he says to the
undercover officer that
he implies that he is killed 49 women
because he's like oh well I was going
for an even 50 but I got sloppy and I'm
paraphrasing but that's pretty much what
he said now if we're going by how many
women were missing from this particular
area and this particular time period
could be as many as 70 because there
were a really lot of women missing from
that area but as far as we know he has
admitted indirectly to killing 49 women
although they haven't found that many
bodies now what they did at first when
they got his stupid ass into custody
they're like okay well we found a [ __ ]
ton of bodies on this farm
now what as they searched through it
because it took a really long time it's
a pretty large piece of property and
they're going through all the [ __ ] and
everything they found tons of like just
pieces and blood and DNA all over the
place what I've heard is that they found
DNA from 80 different people
male and female so now that doesn't
necessarily mean that he killed 80
people that could just be some dudes
that he invited there to like rape
[ __ ] and their semen is in the house
I don't know those big parties - going
on that's what I mean so it doesn't
necessarily mean that he's killed 80
although again just like the pig [ __ ]
it wouldn't surprise me but did he have
any guy friends not men he didn't seem
to have a lot of friends period I mean
like I said he seemed like everyone that
knew him nobody seemed to know him very
okay closely even the guy that worked at
their farm just said he was really hard
to get to know he's very quiet some of
the women like I said that survived that
had like spent time with him were like
well you know he just kept to himself he
was very stoic you and they also a lot
of them said that he was like kind of
they didn't really specify what they
were talking about but they said that he
had he was real quiet he was
they said that he behaved his behavior
was very weird but they wouldn't like go
deeper and what they were talking about
right so I kind of feel like like I said
he wasn't he wasn't a smart dude on the
documentary that I saw they they
compared him to like they said he was
very like cunning like an animal but not
much more than that
now that's kind of an important point to
make because when he first went to trial
what they decided to do was that even
though they suspected that he killed a
shit-ton more people they said what
we're gonna do the judge determined he's
like we're gonna take these six cases
that are the strongest and we're gonna
put those all in one trial now he's like
there are 20 or 21 other charges
he's like we'll do that later because
those are he's like that was a case
where they couldn't match up body parts
or anything like that they're like those
are cases where we just found alleged
possessions of these missing women on
his property you know so it's still
plausible deniability that he didn't
kill them even though I'm sure he
probably did but he's like these six
cases we felt we have the bodies we have
DNA we have all of this [ __ ] so we're
gonna do this because like we don't want
any mistrial we don't want to we want
this [ __ ] in jail so we don't
want anything to go wrong
so they just like you know they just
said work it's just gonna do these six
now his defense argued that essentially
his defense was he is too stupid to have
pulled all of this off by himself that's
awesome they're not saying that he
didn't do it they're just saying oh well
there must have been a like his brother
David or somebody like that there must
have been somebody else because he was
you dumb it's called the dumb ass dumb
[ __ ] stupid yeah I don't know how to
cut up people just like you would cut up
a pig like it takes a smart person to do
that yeah that's what whatever but you
know I'm you
I know I know defense lawyers they gotta
have an angle that's just how it works
but that was the angle they chose
because I guess that was the only one
they had available to them they're like
look at him for Christ's sake he's too
dumb to kill although it's this stupid
stinky mother [ __ ] sitting here in
the courtroom right there's no way he
could have done all this and all these
others so that was essentially yeah now
in a way I'm not gonna say it worked
because it didn't work cuz he's in
prison but they were going for
first-degree murder um there was some
controversy about one of the jurors and
I don't know if this is true or not but
one of the jurors was like dead set
against like thinking he was innocent
and all this other kind of stuff and
like there was all this big thing about
it but like I said I don't know if
that's necessarily true I've read that
and a couple of sources but when the
verdict came back they ended up giving
him second-degree murder six counts of
second-degree murder for a serial killer
yeah but well it ended up okay though
because they said well because of all
these counts of second sorry the cat's
makin yeah she's just like she's tearing
the place up she I have like a little
thing of paper back there and that's
like her face - OH - well let's see this
no I can't reach I can't reach it don't
worry about it I was trying to show you
guys she's it's a sight to see
stop doing it stop it well yeah so yeah
she loves to like tear that paper of a
chew and stuff she leaves like a big
thing and that she's like she's asleep
now yeah but yeah so they they sent
second-degree murder I guess because
they thought diminished capacitor was
too stupid but also the judge kind of
allowed it because they said okay well
six counts of second-degree murder he's
gonna get a prison forever anyway so it
doesn't really matter whether it was
first degree murder or second degree
murder yes because he's not getting it's
gonna just hit him with the system yeah
that's pretty much what they did now the
[ __ ] up thing about it though is that
like ice
there were 20 or 21 more counts that are
still I don't think they're necessarily
pending because I think they thought why
bother we're just gonna close it because
he's already in prison forever and you
know we're not just gonna go through all
the trouble of this even though I'm sure
the families would probably like to see
like some justice for their particular
relative or whatever but I don't think
they're gonna do it at this point just
because he's already in there and I feel
like it would just probably be
superfluous yeah but I don't know it's
kind of [ __ ] up and it seems kind of
[ __ ] up when you're like oh there's
all these [ __ ] charges that they're
never gonna hit him with just because
right it was just but you know they did
what they should have done at the start
they said okay well these six murders we
have their bodies we have the DNA we
know that he killed them because we
found like their skulls in half and
their [ __ ] blood and everything on
this they're just doing what they're
just doing it the easiest way that they
can to defend the right [ __ ] Canadian
public really yeah and they just said we
want enough right you know enough
charges that will stick that he's not
gonna get off on a technicality that
he's not gonna then he'll just be
imprisoned and he'll be away from
everybody and it won't be so what's
happening next well basically I mean
they did like I said they did a huge
excavation that was the problem I know
what is your problem what did she weighs
down I'm not doing anything turn your
back again yeah yeah so like I said they
excavated as much as the proper as much
of the property they could they found
all kinds of horrible [ __ ] like not only
bodies and stuff but also all kind of
bondage gear weapons all kind of [ __ ] so
as I said they found the DNA from 80
different victims they don't know if all
those are murder victims
he has obliquely admitted to killing 49
women because he said to the undercover
officer I wanted to go for an even 50
but I messed it up I got sloppy and I
got caught so they're assuming that he's
killed 49 but technically he's been
convicted of six and you know might be
charged with 20 or 21 more so 27 I think
his sort of total that they give even
though they think it's probably fun done
and could be as high as 70 Bundy would
have called this guy a bottom-feeder he
was yeah he said you know what funny
would have been like man it's easy to
kill that many women if they're [ __ ]
broke-ass hookers well you have good
college girls yeah these are and we've
mentioned this before it's it's kind of
shitty because I mean these are poor
women they're you know some of them are
just teenagers this is [ __ ] up but I
read online this this neighborhood in
Vancouver at the low track they're like
there's even a particular street on
there where you can go get underage
hookers it's just 11 year old girls and
[ __ ] like strolling up a street I don't
know if that's true just say if you're
from Canada don't tell me but I've just
read that somewhere
ole Dennis would have put it like this
understand sometimes sometimes this just
happens infertile income areas where you
have guys are they're not gonna control
themselves you know yeah and you know
not a good man not upstanding not not a
man that the community can depend on
definitely another question wait some
men have sexual problems some men have
sexual problems yeah mmm he didn't have
sexual problems like me nah my sexual
problems were not this bad just got here
I've Channel and Dennis Rader again that
was it I want you people to understand
something what happens on those pick
farms it's bad it's bad there there
there we have to get governmental
control over pit farms in case things
were abused like that yeah put me in
charge of the big fight if you'll
release me I'll go out and I'll make
sure that that's a very fantastic don't
happen all the pig farms yeah yeah
you'll be in charge of all the pig farms
making sure that none of these
shenanigans can take place I have an
irish-american background you know yeah
I know what shenanigans are all about
see my catering
shenanigans and Shanaya chicane Ruiz I
was gifted with a certain DNA spot
shanna shenanigans we could use that to
help the government yeah keep these
people under control hmm I've been
gifted with very special gifts to see
this I can spot it I can ruin it out a
special badge give me a special badge
and I'll do it for you just let me out
yeah that was dance dance that's what
dad has had to say yeah Thank You Dennis
he's always so insightful and all of
these true crime shows Dennis Rader man
named shower you know didn't shower yes
he I figured you would not approve this
individual or not these are all
prostitute women and it's unacceptable
yeah and this like I said this is a man
that slept with figs maybe [ __ ] things
allegedly allegedly we can surmise that
yeah you're sleeping into bed with a pig
sometimes you know [ __ ] happens - all
right so I've heard you know right so
okay you guys you can't see this she's
trying to go underneath pillows there's
two pillows over there like on the floor
and she's like trying to like scooch
underneath them like oh look I'm making
a cake she tried to go underneath my
oriental rug yeah she came out the other
side she goes rug isn't forever I
thought it was like a portal yeah she
like she made a towel she like picked up
her pond she made like a little tunnel
and then she like went through it and
they went all the way yeah she's like
whoohoo and she's like this doesn't go
anywhere yeah I'm in the same room
I might really [ __ ] down so it's at
the end of this show pretty much like I
said they they don't really know because
they found so much DNA on this farm and
as I said they tore all the buildings
down now it's like you can't go on it
but they've kind of taken it over just
in case but they don't really know
what he did to these women their
surmising that you know he would go he
would pick them up later on he would get
his female friends to go pick them up
and bring them back like hey come party
with you know porkchop Rob you know he's
the best he has money and drugs right
which he was which is that that was to
me they like the freakiest [ __ ]
detail so they bring the prostitutes
back some of them he let go like I said
because some of them didn't really have
anything bad to say about him but for
whatever reason every now and then he
would find what he's like yeah I'm gonna
handcuff this one to bed rape her and
then he would either shoot them or
strangle them hang them in his
slaughterhouse cut them open like a pig
now they think that beat him do y'all
yeah either fed them to his other pigs
like because he had he had some pigs
that like I said he sold for meat
he also had a really big like a
600-pound boar that was kind of like the
farm pet and also guard dog like it
would kind of go around the perimeter
and like bite people and [ __ ] yeah so
they think that he might have either
ground the women up and fed them to the
pigs or ground them up because I think
they did find on the property a couple
of garbage bags full of like ground-up
human meat so they think also that he
took some of them perhaps to the
rendering plant as I said or he sold
some of them mixed in with the pork that
he was selling to the public and this I
was watching the documentary I think it
was on the biography channel now that
I'm thinking about it but so I'm
watching the documentary about that you
getting rid of trouble yes but um this
poor woman who was I think she was the
niece of one of the victims and she was
talking about when they first heard when
the government came out and said you
know if you bought pork from this guy or
from this particular rendering planner
you bought products from there you might
have eaten human you know might want to
go get that checked out and she said I
hung this [ __ ] documentary she says
like yeah I may have
my aunt and I was like oh my god that is
[ __ ] up I could have been and for her
to like say that it's like oh my god I
wouldn't even be able to like get this
[ __ ] words out that's like a [ __ ]
horrifying thing that [ __ ] I mean on
top of everything else now like I said
they never proved it but from what they
found at the farm
they're just extrapolating here in the
US bit what is probably that's what
happened here in the u.s. people would
have sued the cops and the government
for them even saying that you may be
your family but you have to know because
if you've eaten human you could get like
you you get mad cow but human human
madcap no no same thing you get like the
bronze right because that's why that's
why cows get mad cow from eating of the
cab eating other cows yeah cows yeah
yeah kuru yeah from humans eating other
few with like cannibals get what cows
don't it's the same thing they're eating
other cows because the cows got mixed in
with the feed woman yeah that's what
that's where mad cow comes from because
they don't it's not like oh [ __ ] no I
don't have that okay no I'm just saying
well okay this is what happened I lived
in the UK in the 90s when the whole Mad
Cow scare was going on so now every time
if I go to give blood like I went to the
Red Cross or I was at a con or something
she can't give and they said have did
you live in the UK between like 1995 and
whatever and I was like yeah I did did
you eat before you were there yeah well
we don't want your blood right it's not
because they think oh but they're like
we don't have a test for that okay
that's why because they don't have a
test for they can because it doesn't
manifest until you get older right so
somebody can stay in like your system
for like a really long time it has like
a really long like incubation okay so
what are the symptoms in case you start
coming down with it I'll recognize it
[Laughter]
it'd be it will basically manifest like
dementia oh well you're there you go you
got it
I have demand you got that [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy as hell
oh stop okay I'm not
I know you're way crazier than I am and
you're not that crazy but you're
definitely yeah no [ __ ]
I haven't even got through one drink and
you're on again - and I'm cooking like
yeah but song low it's on low that's
like yeah yeah so I can't believe work I
can't believe her rapping of a show
about Willy picked in the pig farmer
killer yeah go eat hot dogs we didn't
he's like hey you want some was because
we have not generated dogs yet yeah he's
like you know I'm like yeah that sounds
good and then I was like talking about
the show and I'm like oh [ __ ] like super
insensitive we ate all day I didn't eat
all day a little crackers and cheese
soup while you're at the office I was
like I was like munching out all day
little munchies yes I was like don't do
this we [ __ ] it's not you it's you okay
I had a bowl of soup me then I had a
bowl of soup and a little piece of bread
okay that's all I've had all day long
and that was you were at the doctor's
office yeah I had that way you were gone
yeah but it's it that was like though
that was like nine hours ago I haven't
eaten for nine [ __ ] airports I got I
got it coming I know that's right show
up Willy
all right yeah we have to go you but our
hotdogs that hopefully don't have any
human meat in them but I'm sure they
probably will knowing how hot dogs are
made I'm just saying all right
yeah well lips and [ __ ] that's what
my dad always yeah lips and [ __ ]
that's all right they're delicious with
ketchup on them I know that's like I
like ketchup and relish on all right but
so that will wrap it up for I know I'm
just I'm so lame yeah I know I know it's
bad I'm - I'm not ashamed though because
that's good
okay I don't put it on I'll put on steak
or not them but it's like it's gonna a
little bit's gonna hotdog catch my
relish and sometimes a little bit of
mayo all right so that will do it for
episode 140 about porkchop Rob Willy
[ __ ] picton one of the worst Canadian
serial killers
all time the pig farmer killer what's
coming back so you know and I'm glad we
had an insight from Dennis Rader about
what a scumbag that dude was and how
he's so much better
this person intelligent man take a
shower didn't you know going after he's
a bottom feeder he's hanging out with
pigs it's disgusting yeah he was in
violation had many violations in his
safety code this standard his grass was
too much was too hard the pigs were you
know not fed properly and I would have
find him
definitely yeah yeah Thank You Dennis I
appreciate you're welcome you're welcome
Jenni I'm glad thirteen o'clock
even though Tom's an [ __ ] well he
does yeah all right are you done I'm
done okay all right so that'll do as I
said now remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media share with all your friends and
family if you would like to financially
support the show would be much
appreciated you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
where press calm and there's a little
button in the sidebar where it'll go to
a PayPal account where you can give a
one-time donation if you'd like to
remember go check out our friend Rob
Levinson he's a friend and a patron of
the show he's making a movie called
where were you and he has an IndieGoGo
there's a link in the show description
if you'd like to go check that out and
help him out with this movie then go do
that also our last movie review was the
rape revenge vigilante film is 45 by
Abel Ferrara's so go check that out if
you haven't already and that will do it
for our latest episode we will see you
next time bye see you alright see you
guys around
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]